[Music]
here in this video we will take a deeper
look into the predator aliens we will
focus on their origins biology life
cycle and how they became the deadly
interplanetary hunters
so let's get to it
origins the yautja are a sentient
humanoid alien race that breathe an
atmosphere similar to that of earth's
but possess an extreme level of
technological advancement
there are two origin stories for this
alien monster the first one tells us
that it is a highly advanced species
that originated in the planet called the
alger prime their primitive ancestors
were called the hish
and they were enslaved by an insecticide
alien species called the amengi which
they later revolted against and secured
their freedom another origin story was
told in the comics predator home world
where it was theorized that they evolved
from ancient earth animals called the
therapists which had both mammalian and
reptilian characteristics they were then
later experimented on by aliens that
took them off world most probably the
engineers or they evolved on earth
millions of years ago and for some
unknown reasons they migrated from earth
to yautja prime so take your pick which
origin story is the better one
let's look at their morphology so these
predators are bipedal humanoids that are
physically different from humans and
that they are taller ranging from seven
to eight feet in the common subspecies
and up to 11 feet as in the case of the
genetically enhanced ultimate version
they have long hair like appendages on
their heads known as dreadlocks and they
lack a nose their skulls are bulbous and
seem to look like an oval-shaped fruit
with borders having a hot osteodome-like
outgrowth just before the dreadlocks
grow out of it their eyes are situated
on the front within a very hollow eye
socket and there are multiple rows of
hair like quills that grow on their face
chest shoulders upper arms maybe even
their backs and their feet but the most
distinguishable feature of theirs are
the four mandibles that are present on
either side of their mouths which are
lined by long sharp teeth which they can
use to eat or defend themselves or even
fight with
okay next their inner biology so anyway
let's take a look what is inside of
these jolly reggae killers the skull of
these predators house of brain which is
way larger than that of any human thus
giving them a higher intelligence but
also their enlarged frontal lobes mean
one thing they are a species with
predatorial senses honed to the optimal
level and thus explaining their
aggressiveness and their killer
instincts their eyes are different to
humans in a way that they can see in a
higher wavelength of the electromagnetic
spectrum in short they have thermal and
infrared vision
they have a similar digestive system
surprisingly to earthly carnivores which
is inferred through the scene of one of
them being able to consume animal meat
on earth as seen in the city hunter
eating meat from the slaughterhouse
these predators are cold-blooded and
hence their affinity towards hot and
humid climates their blood is
bioluminescent and shines in the
phosphor green color and has the
capacity to partially neutralize the
acidity of the xenomorph blood well
partially at least it also has been
known to be capable of extending a human
lifespan well beyond that would be
normally possible if infused into the
body of a person
they are highly resilient to physical
damage
they are capable of recovering from
multiple gunshot wounds and with minimal
or even no medical attention meaning
that they have a very high regeneration
factor
they are also resilient to radioactivity
and are immune to most viruses and
microbes in short their genetic material
far surpasses that of earthly creatures
and humans
so next let's look at their life cycle
well it's quite a common life cycle a
simple one the yavja are similar to
earth animals in that they exist in two
pairs
two sexes the male and the female
although most specimens that have been
encountered are males there are a few
individuals that are females most
importantly the matriarch which
female
achieves when she is blooded they do not
lay eggs but give birth to life young
which are called sucklings these
sucklings are raised in a village
raising kind of situation with no
parenthood which shows that their
lifestyle is devoid of intimate parents
the young ones only grow to become
adults when they are around 50 to 60
years equivalent to a person of 18 to 19
years of age
because they age slower than humans
their lifespan seems to stretch out for
thousands of years one of the longest
living species in their universe
only surpassed by the xenomorph queens
for instance
then there is the predalien life cycle
which although isn't really a predator
can be counted as one of their hybrids
since their highly effective dna gave
the predalien a more predator look than
a xenomorph okay let's talk a little bit
on this then their genetic enhancements
on themselves and then get to their
growth stages
the pre-alien life cycle starts with a
xenomorph egg also called an overmorph
which houses a creepy looking spidery
creature called a facehugger this
facehugger then implants the xeno embryo
into a predator by latching onto its
neck with its long tail and with a long
mouth-to-mouth alien french kills it
inserts the embryo right into its throat
then going down to its digestive system
and there it grows and after some time a
young chest burster alien will pop out
and grow into a 3 meter tall or a 10
feet tall pretty alien which is one of
the most powerful
versions of a predator aside from the
ultimate one
next these predators are also known to
be highly advanced in genetic
engineering and also to modify their own
genomes in order to adapt and evolve
without the need to undergo through
natural selection let's say
instances where this is seen is in the
movie the predator where the two yautjas
or predators seen on earth weren't
anything like the normal hunter variants
the first one the fugitive might look
like a hunter variant but had human dna
which gave him rudimentary understanding
of human culture and language and even
humor
the next one which is the big ultimate
predator had many genetic enhancements
and giving it unusual abilities making
him 11 feet tall with bulletproof skin
bionic cybernetic enhancements and
digital great legs and that's about it
so that's the unique variations of their
life cycles otherwise it's life young
and they grow into adults
okay lastly let's look at their growth
stages
so yeah as we've said before these
sucklings or young yautja grow in a
village raising kind of parenthood which
takes around 50 years or more and over
the long period of time they are trained
in many forms of hunting and warfare
techniques these young predators cannot
go out on hunts on their own until they
go through a specific hunting ritual
called blooding
and until then they are under adult
supervision
though not required
when they are blooded the newly blooded
predators typically
form prestigious bloodlines and can
undergo further training by retired
predators
a blooded yautja will occasionally serve
as adjutants for a hunting party next to
a leader acting as a secondary overseer
and after that they go solo
and that's about it and i hope you have
enjoyed watching this video about the
origins biology and life cycle of the
predators so do hit that like button for
support and subscribe but most of all
smash that bell icon for regular updates
on new videos right here on this channel
till the next one take care fam